désormais incontournable elle est la
révélation jazz soul de l'année 2012 et
elle fait découvrir depuis son album
Nothing for granted au public elle sera
notamment le 19 avril en concert au
scarabé à La Verrière voici sandran kqué
dans le
[Musique]
kiosque l'envie de chanter je pense que
elle date d' y a très très longtemps
enfin je m'étais jamais imaginé que ce
serait mon métier en tout cas ma ma
manière de communiquer avec les gens
j'ai toujours écouté beaucoup de musique
j'ai toujours chanté au départ je
voulais être journaliste ou professeur
donc c'est pour ça je m'étais inscrite à
la sbonne pour entreprendre des des
grandes études et puis en fait c'est un
c'est un hasard parce que je chantais
tout le temps dans les couloirs et une
copine m'a proposé de de passer une
audition pour un groupe qu'elle
connaissait et puis j'ai eu envie d'y
aller parce que j'aime bien les j'aime
bien me lancer des défis faire des
choses que j'ai jamais fait et voilà
donc j'ai passé l'audition en me disant
que je serais pas prise et j'étais
[Musique]
prise et là ça a été le début de d'un
d'un long apprentissage de voilà de la
découverte de la voix de de plein de
styles de musique différentes parce que
moi à l'époque écoutais beaucoup de
musique classique de folk c'était un
groupe de funk donc je connaissais pas
du tout cette musique là donc c'était
assez drôle et puis en parallèle j'ai
rencontré des des comédiens des metteurs
en scène et puis j'ai commencé à faire
du théâtre et pendant 10 15 ans j'ai
j'ai joué sur les deux tableaux on va
dire j'ai toujours fait des spectacles
qui incluent de la musique et et des
histoires et puis j'ai fait pas mal de
de cœur aussi j'ai accompagné des
groupes Olano R
rosof
[Musique]
oui c'est c'est mon deuxè album j'avais
envie pour cet album là de donner un peu
plus corps à à des questionnements qui
sont à la fois personnels mais qu'on
peut tous qu'on peut tous avoir quant au
choix dans notre vie des choix de vie
intime des choix de vie professionnelle
comment élever ses enfants qu'est-ce
comment on est quelour d'animal social
on est qu'est-ce qu'on se permet de de
de faire et à la fois dans la société
mais dans la petite société que
représente la famille aussi qu'on est
tous plus ou moins formaté en tout cas
formé dans des cadres et que parfois on
a l'impression d'être à côté du cadre et
qu'on le vit pas toujours bien et cet
album là c'était à la fois pour moi mais
aussi pour les autres une manière de
dire que on peut on peut se surpasser on
peut on a le droit d'exprimer ça sa
personnalité sa
singularité le fait qu'on est un peu en
marche qu'on est un peu
[Musique]
bancal Enie que ça passe par par des
personnages parce que c'est pas
spécialement quel chose
d'autobiographique en tout cas éléments
biographiques qu'il y a ne sont utilisés
que parce qu'ils ont valeur de de de
généralité et donc c'est à la fois des
destins individuels des destins
collectifs c'est une manière de dire que
il faut il faut se battre pour ses idées
il faut se battre pour ce à quoi on
croit et que que les choix qu'on fait
sont très importants la manière dont on
fait les choses les personnes dont on
s'entour pour faire les choses c'est
pour ça que que que je travaille entre
guillemets en famille c'est une famille
artistique une famille humaine avant
tout et pour la album et sur
[Musique]
scène le CH en anglais parce que moi je
suis camerounaise et qu'on parle anglais
et français et que il fallait faire un
choix je sais pas je pense que le il s
fa il s'est fait tout seul j'écris aussi
en français je me suis en fait on me
pose souvent la question peut-être qu'il
faudrait que je me la pose je sais pas
euh parce qu' on utilise les deux
langues donc je jealité pe non je pense
que le français aussi musical que que
que l'anglais que l'italien c'est après
je pense que c'est peut-être un rapport
à l'intime je sais pas euh peut-être
qu'il faudrait que j'en parle à un
psychanaliste j'aime les deux euh je
m'interdis rien mais c'est vrai que pour
l'instant c'est majoritairement en
anglais même si j'ai fait notamment une
reprise de la mauvaise réputation euh
j'ai fait aussi une reprise du bal perdu
de de Bourville que j'ai pas fait encore
en disque j'ai aussi pas mal de chansons
français mais j'ai pas encore
[Musique]
enregistré je pense que la musique que
je fais se mettrait dans le dans ce qui
s'appelle le grand bac de la de la soul
musique qui est une petite sœur du du
blues en tout cas voilà c'est raconter
des histoires qui peuvent toucher les
gens donc être le plus le plus sincère
possible donc j'essaie à chaque album
d'être le le plus moi possible en
imaginant que ça pourra éventuellement
intéresser des gens merci Beaucoup de
rien
merci et maintenant un nouveau sujet de
la rédaction oh regarde regarde le beau
sujet làhaut
magnifique Faur de rire dénicheur de
talent papi encore démontrer ce mardi
soir à la ferme du Mousseau à hencour
l'étendue de son savoir-faire son choix
s'est porté sur qu jeunes humoristes en
devenir pour un spectacle découverte
d'univers très
varié on est dans la configuration du
plateauonir la chance ce soir de d'avoir
effectivement univers différents qui
vont venir défendre les uns après les
autres leur leur univers donc pour le
public c'est l'occasion de d'avoir ce
panel là d'humoriste complètement
différent après je vais faire
l'introduction des uns et des autres
mais c'est juste en mettre de cérémonie
de ce spectacle c'est surtout une
rencontre avec le public c'est une
rencontre pour eux c'est un public
différent on n'est pas à Paris on est
dans un public qui va venir qui découvre
peut-être pour la première fois ce que
c'est que le standup qui est une
particularité quand même dans dans le
monde humoristique et puis en plus il y
avait l'idée sur sur encour et sur
Saint-Quentin bah de montrer un peu ce
travail que de suivi artistique que nous
menons aussi avec des clics quoi ah ben
ça c'est toute la
jouréeon Julie Galibert ou encore kan
kojandi connu pour sa miniérie bref se
sont succédés sur scène pour une soirée
passée dans le rire et la bonne humeur
doublé
chuchotter ce qui est intéressant c'est
est-ce que les gens vont être assez
curieux pour venir voir l'intégralité du
spectacle là ils vont avoir juste un
aperçu avec un seul personnage voilà
pendant 20 minutes est-ce que ça va leur
donner envie assez envie pour pouvoir
voir l'ensemble c'est quoi ici c'est la
f forine non c'est pas la f forine
on je reprends là où j'en étais avant
c'est-à-dire je reprends par la par la
petite porte l'humour et je crée mon
humour s'agit d'être marrant et soi-même
c'est ça le vrai combat papi j'ai
rencontré à l'époque il y a
juste avant bref en fait c'était il
m'avait il m'avait embauché dans la
troupe du Jamel Comedy Club il avait la
gestion de la troupe super moment et
avec lui j'ai compris des vraiment des
super trucs de pas forcément mettre
d'enjeu dans sa prestation juste de
mettre du plaisir et de la recherche et
de la
création sur avec le public et ça
c'était assz assez cool et puis c'est un
mec super détendu il m'a invité il m'a
dit ouais petite sal je avec plaisir
parce que papi ça se refuse
pas comme leurs aînés Jamel de B ou SOP
ai accpagn par PAP serontil conquérir le
public Julie Galibert sera le 20 avril
opéré en Eveline pour l'intégralité de
son spectacle c'est arrivé près de chez
elle quant à kan kojandi en dehors des
planches il travaille aussi à
l'adaptation de bref au cinéma
tu et encore quelques dates à retenir
avant de liker la page Facebook du
kiosque le 19 avril ibrine marlou sera
en concert prisme à H encour les blod
Dravel présenteront quant à eux leur
nouveau spectacle l'homme d'habitude le
20 avril à la Merise à trrappe et enfin
la pièce à succès thé à laament ou th
citron sera la Ferme du Manet à mantini
le Bretonneux le 21 avril des dates que
vous pouvez retrouver sur internet aux
adresses qui s'affichent et n'oubliez
pas que chaque semaine sur le
www.kiosk.ski.fr vous pouvez gagner des
places de spectacle alors enjoy comme
disait JNS et à
bientôt
qui que c'est
cool